originaire de chevreuse marisa l'uso est
une pique roquettes depuis 2010 9 elle
joue demi de mêlée dans l'équipe
féminine du stade français paris en
élite une le plus haut niveau du rugby
féminin l'ovalie elle l'a dans le sang
son père a présidé le club de chevreuse
et ses frères ont joué au rugby
chevreuse à une petite ville de campagne
tout l'école élémentaire tout le monde
fait aussi pratique du rugby
tout le monde se connaît donc du coup de
bouche à oreille avec les copains
forcément envie d'y prendre goût donc
fait du coup on tente éducatrice
spécialisée de profession marisa l'uso
organise son planning pour être la plus
performante elle a eu la chance d'être
sélectionné en équipe de france lors du
tournoi des six nations en 2010 9 à
l'époque j'étais assistant d'éducation
donc acheté dans le bureau et je reçois
la paix joie qui est ce que c'était
c'était pendant la période du tournoi
des six nations
donc du coup je me pose des questions et
donc du coup unique héros la manager
actuel m'appelle et me fais la
proposition de participer à un stage de
regroupement avec le 15 pour la semaine
de de l'italie deuxième ou troisième
mine au stade français paris clotilde
embarré est arrivé en 2016 avant cela
elle a joué à la mls gp maisons laffitte
saint germain poissy une équipe où elle
a développé ses capacités rugbystique
c'est mon premier club d'adultes entre
guillemets donc c'était énormément de
découverte mais que des coupes découvert
positive avec des jets énormément de
chance parce que je suis tombé sur des
coaches qui m'ont tout de suite fait
confiance c'est que des moments hyper
hyper riches ou chantés qui a vraiment
du soutien de la part du club vis-à-vis
des féminines ce qui n'est pas forcément
le cas dans tant d'autres clubs
l'équipe féminine du stade français a
été créé il ya une dizaine d'années les
potentiels sont repérés dans les clubs
franciliens
c'était le cas pour marissa l'uso et
clotilde de l'an barre et déjà ces deux
joueuses très travailleuse
très exigeante avec elle même qui adore
travailler donc venir venir faire des
séances au quotidien que ce soit en
salle de musculation
que ce soit le mardi et le jeudi sur le
terrain que ce soit le mercredi sur des
séances spécifiques elles sont toujours
présentes très à l'écouté
au niveau sportif marisa l'uso et
clotilde embarré sont engagés avec les
pink roquette dans la course au maintien
cette saison pour pouvoir conserver leur
place en élite une